hey guys and welcome to a brand new
video today I'm going to be flipping
with 100 mil in free-to-play I have
never actually tried with this much
money before and now before I get
started I know I'm going to be cheating
a bit here I'm not gonna be using a
free-to-play account because only having
three offer slots it's just gonna be way
too painful and I can't I can't do it
unfortunately it should be too much of
it piss off but we are gonna be doing
only free-to-play items just as kind of
a challenge obviously nobody's getting
100 mil in free-to-play very easily or
probably ever but I still think it's
cool and yeah let's get started okay to
start off here we have GE tracker open
that they are responsive mine so go
check them out if you haven't there will
be a link in the description for them
but we're gonna be mainly starting with
the high volume part here as we have
soft clay you logs and all a bunch of
other free-to-play items and that we
have the GE limits page here now the
high smartin paid for free play is
always a bit of a crapshoot because most
of these items are very slow so they're
not almost worth doing okay let's start
off here we're gonna try the wine of
zamorak nice expensive item 16 22 into
1650 pretty good I will do 10,000 of
those which is actually pretty expensive
or if we play them bump that down a bit
and hopefully has come to relatively
quickly and if we have a look at the buy
and sell
there is 188 thousand a day which is a
fair amount okay next up death ruins
have a 3gp margin not that great but not
a lot option so we'll do death runes for
about 2.5 mm and la Bruins have a 2gp
margin we'll do that as well quickly
tosses in here and the nature UNS have a
two GP margin on them as well which is
pretty common another ten thousand of
those guys and the death runes are
almost all the way through and next up
we're going to do great have a 5 GP
margin on them I think grapes are a 10k
limit as well maybe it says here
somewhere actually 13 thousands will
take advantage of that twelve to nine
ninety and that's four mil invested
there okay energy potions is a really
good flip for 35 into for 85 see if we
keep that and these guys are only two
gained fortunately would love to dump
more money in there
and I'm sure we're gonna do with all
this money let's find something
expensive okay we're gonna price check
the hill giant Club because I just
wanted what the price is 683 into 661
and we'll try that why not and we'll do
five of these guys for now and then
we're gonna sell off all these law runes
for a 20k profit not too bad
so those off perfect okay and the last
step we're gonna try the Adamantite or
1228 into 1265 pretty good margin and we
can dump 4500 of these into the G it
seems like as a limit solute 4490 and
that's five mil so it's a good chunk of
change in there okay all the grapes came
through for a 3:11 that's pretty nice
and we'll just double check where we're
gonna sell these guys for grapes and I
think it's a 5 GP margin I got 3 17
pretty nice chuck those in there that's
an easy 60 K 41 1 8 from 43 9 pretty
nice ok then we're gonna pull out the
death runes for 84 8 9 of them check
mine for 249 we've gone for 246 that's
three GP is better than waiting problem
to complete in the margin go down I
guess okay so I find an expensive item
was a good margin that is the Rue Knight
bar only is 830 GP margin which I would
not normally do but just because I have
so much spare cash here we'll check in
for a thousand okay we sold off all the
death rooms for close to a 30k profit
which is pretty good okay we bought a
ton of Runet bar is so quick actually
2.8 K of them which is really nice I
think I'll work on selling those first
because we did get a few more as amarak
wines come through as well at 12:55 wine
and we're selling them for twelve five
eighty I think we just lucked out there
so we're getting about 30 on each one of
those so for every 1,000 that will be 30
ka times for this 120k just from these
rune ight bars which doesn't seem like
amazing but it is actually pretty good
okay we're gonna take a second to toss
in nature runes in and Lorenz came
through we bought them for 227 I believe
or not too
it's only 20k in the lorentz and
hopefully 20k in nature UN's but easy
money okay we're only getting one GP on
the nature and so only 10k or 8.5 K not
even okay we're gonna pull the nature
wounds out they were pretty much all
sold anyway check those that we own in
59 and life two cares about those okay
don't think I'm the one actually do the
hill giant Club it's a very slow item
and I'm even surprised even got the one
I think it's more important for me to
start selling off these mines of zamorak
cuz they're not a very quick item but
they are coming to rent is the heavy
ticket margin on it 23 - yeah it's 40 GP
on these guys so it probably worth
making sure actually sell okay next up
I'm gonna do the mistral bar 8 GP margin
on that that's pretty nice and as a 10 K
by n limit
I'm gonna do that it looks like we'll
get an open on GG tracker here ok has a
10k buy on limit and about 39 K traded
every hour which should be good for us
since we're only doing a third of that
and the last step we're gonna do you
logs for a 5 GP margin that's actually
really good comparative to what I
thought it would be we can do 12,000
these guys 11900 pretty much and that's
pretty much everything filled we'll just
wait a while and hope things sell ok so
we finally sold off the hill giant Club
only a 25k profit on that took about
half an hour so I don't my hats it's not
bad but I don't think I'm gonna bother
of another one well I sold a couple rune
eye bars and readjusted the offer so
this may have been a mistake
because they are not selling off very
quickly ok we're gonna buy some gold
necklaces instead of the logs because
they were really going anywhere we're
gonna do twelve thousand eight hundred
of them going to invest 1.7 million to
that and we did sell off all the admin
or we were selling 20 GP on each of
those means that for every thousand
resale were getting about 20k which is
pretty decent for free-to-play
okay we're gonna stop selling the e-myth
or bar I went and checked a price and it
is not coming through and we have about
20 minutes left to actually sell it all
off to a 24 it's not a huge margin
unfortunately but
it happens sometimes and not very quick
items to be honest we sold another 500
rune 8 bars which is nice keep buying
loads of 500 wines of zamorak haven't
come through for a while so we'll
probably just pull those out the grapes
slowly maybe and the adamantite or is
bit slow as well okay this little faulty
mithril bars so we just got like 20k in
profit on those as well
four two four seven six we bought them
for at three four five eight yeah about
20k okay we're gonna try to fit a couple
quick flips in the air and I will do
some coal and maybe some lobsters we
sold off all the adamantite or which is
nice sell off on the Adamantite or we
got like 20 GP was it
12:42 20 GP and we did a boat well now
2,000 of those it's about 40k from that
not terrible what just happened here
bought it for 144 one sold it for 145 so
we actually have a negative 1 GP margin
149 now and we're gonna buy a poor one
what ok we can give that a try the
things all over the place but who cares
10,000
ok we're also going to do raw lobster
why the [__] not ten thousand of those
let's go coal has come through her for
182 and hopefully we can get maybe 20 K
from this flip okay so we abandoned the
raw lobsters the coal sold off for a 20k
profit pretty good and we have most of
the wines of zamorak sold just like 100
max left I think the cell and it
roommate bars and hopefully we'll end up
selling but I doubt it and grapes
whatever almost done okay we sold off
the lobsters for 144 and buying them for
142 so like a 12 K profit there we're
kind of working out anything we can at
this point honestly five minutes [__] it
let's just ended these vermin eight bars
have not come through in a while now
yeah nope and grapes as well so yeah
let's just claim everything and just
dump the rest of it because it's just
been stagnating for a while now but we
did get some pretty decent margins on
some of these items and has a roommate
I'm a little nervous Forks we still have
quite a bit of money worth of them okay
all right well insula cell lets the
rules claim that perfect and sell off
the grapes and the minds of zamorak and
the gold necklace and we'll see how much
money we made one hour of flipping
free-to-play items from 100ml okay so
clearly a hundred mil isn't very
efficient for free-to-play but I thought
it'd be fun and I did find a couple
items that could actually use up that
amount of capital in free-to-play a
bullet check much money that we made in
the hour it looks like 414 K which again
not great but it is free-to-play now if
you were to actually do this with a
reasonable amount of money you could get
this done with probably 10 mil a tenth
of this and you'd still be able to make
three or four hundred K an hour and
free-to-play of course you might as well
be paid to play at that point that's
irrelevant at this point so the video is
done anyway guys hope you enjoyed the
video if you didn't forget to toss it a
like and I'll see you in the next one
[Music]